I've met with the board of the  conservative party and the executive of  the United Bridge City commission we've  agreed the process as I indicated  earlier it will conclude by Friday the  28th of October the process for the  Parliamentary stages of the contest will  begin now nominations are now open uh  we'll close at two o'clock on Monday  candidates will be expected to have at  least 100  colleagues nominating them nominations  can be accepted either by signature or  by email we will then go on to conduct  whatever ballots are necessary during  the course of Monday  and when we reach two final candidates  we will also conduct an indicative  ballot so that it is clear what the  balance or prefer difference within the  Parliamentary party is